welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they will float with the
it's super cut being announced earlier
this week I thought it was time to break
down everything we know about the
upcoming release the supercut will
contain both films as well as all of the
deleted scenes and even some new ones to
flesh out the entire story of the losers
Club the original cut of it chapter two
came in at four hours so that was a lot
a minute from the release that we'll
finally see the light of day with this
new extended edition throughout this
video I'm just going to be going over
everything we know so far all of the
deleted content that will be added back
in and what we can expect in the new
additions there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't seen the film yet
that I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
it super cut okay so the first scene
that we know will be included in the
super cut showcases summer Pennywise his
backstory most notably the well house
which is seen in a painting when Ben is
sitting in the library this scene set in
the 1600s had a formless Pennywise
appearing and it would show the creature
chasing a woman with her baby through
the well house before finally trapping
her in a room the woman pleaded with
penny wise did not eat her or a family
to which penny wise says that he will
not kill them as long as she lets it
have the baby in this scene the woman
then puts the baby on the floor and
leaves the room and we would see a bald
red Pennywise slowly circle it we would
later learn that the well house would in
fact become the house on neo belt street
and the well itself would become the
entrance to penny wises lair this also
has scene where we see Henry Bowers
going mad after slowly being driven
insane by the torment of penny wise and
we pick up with bill after fleeing from
the basement during the scene in which
Georgie appeared in it he pleads with
his father to check the basement because
of how flooded it is and how Georgie is
down there his father goes into the
basement and we hear him wading through
the water before coming up and saying
that it's as dry as a bone
this mirrors the scene with Beverly in
which her father was enabled to see
blood and also showcases how Pennywise
has a psychic effect over the
townspeople so that it can continue to
operate in kidnapping children we also
see Henry Bowers in a car stalking the
losers before the attack in the house of
near bolt Street and he's also killed
his friends this mirrors his appearance
in it chapter 2 in which he followed
them with a car before attacking them
the final scene added for the super cut
would be Bill moving away with his
parents to Arcadia at the end of the
movie he looks at his hand with his scar
of the earth before getting in the car
and leaving the area to go on and become
a successful writer and this scene
cements how he managed to get away from
Derry going on to the second film now
which will still be part of the super
car the first scene that we saw in
trailers for its chapter two that didn't
make it to the film is Pennywise jumping
out of the wall with Mike looking up at
him
this scene actually centered around Mike
returning to the burned-out building
where his parents died in order to find
a token to help him fight the clown in
the ritual of Jude at the location when
Mike returned Pennywise was going to
taunt Mike over the death of his parents
and say that it was their fault of the
building burned down and there was also
going to be the corpse of a young girl
who died in the fire screaming out at
him which would hammer home that Mike's
parents were responsible throughout the
film Mike believes that his parents were
drug addicts due to a newspaper title
however later in the film we see this
changes upon the defeat of Pennywise
showing that the character has always
mistakenly believed that his parents
were the ones to blame the title of the
paper was revealed to say two locals
died serving neighbours daughter from
electrical blaze and would cement that
they were heroes rather than simply
addicts this scene reiterates Mike's
guild as well as how he feels towards
his mother and father and will also
flesh out Mike going back for a token
moving on from this in the original
script when going to get his token been
visited the quarry instead of the school
and this is where he was confronted by
the severely burned Beverley that taunts
and chases him whether they will switch
this up for the super cut or keeper as
the school remains to be seen but they
might change the scenes up to show
viewers what they could have gotten in
the final cut the quarry also appears at
the end of the film though which I'll
get into later so this might have been
deemed too repetitive in addition to
this the scene in which Beverly visits
her home and runs into mrs. Kirsch would
be far longer than the version that we
saw
the theatrical cut in the trailer for
the film in which this scene was first
shown there were several elements of it
that didn't make it to the final release
and thus we know that a lot got left on
the cutting room floor this includes the
way in which mrs. Kirsch transforms with
her originally doing it in front of
Beverly in the concept art as well as
her teeth falling out during it upon
leaving the house a balloon with the
words sweet dreams bevy would also
appear on top of this when mrs. Kirsch
pulls Beverley under water on the way to
Penny wises lair that was also a scene
in which the two fought it out in the
film this moment seems a bit jarring as
she's pulled under the losers Club dive
in to save her and then emerge without
there really being much of a struggle
this scene was gone to flesh out this
encounter and also show them tackling
Kirsch and freeing Beverly from the
creature Jessica Chastain was injured
during this so it's a shame that we
never got to see it but if you're
looking for things to cut then I guess
this doesn't really add all that much
fans have also cried out for Mature in
the tale to appear in a version of it
but borrow a few references it's never
made an appearance however in the
original cut of the film when the losses
returned to the quarry they would once
more spot a turtle underwater similar to
how they did in the first film I promise
to cover the turtle one day in the video
but Andy machete director of the film
has said that he does want to flesh out
more of mature ins appearances in the
film this ties in with the fact that
mache has also said that he's working on
bringing new scenes to the movie for the
supercut and in an interview with été he
stated we're in talks with the studio to
make a super cut which is basically the
two movies edited together with all the
material that is not in the released
versions and yeah there are a couple of
scenes that I want to shoot to make this
a new experience one thing is from the
novel and the other thing is not I want
to be a little cryptic about it he later
went on to say to Entertainment Weekly
when discussing the possibility of a
third film it would have to be the right
type of approach to it the book ends
where the second movie ends so that is
the final chapter of the story there is
this interesting aspect of going back in
time before this all happened there
might be a story there that might be
worth exploring obviously that would be
a story that's not in the book it would
be a free-standing story but obviously
within the same universe so there might
be something
interesting out of it I think it would
be fun so the new scene could
potentially focus more on penny wisest
origin story and its attack on the early
settlers of Derry as well as the
colonies that he wiped out which is paid
lip-service to in the first film either
way there's a lot to look forward to and
I would love to have a mega cut that
viewers can just sit and come back to
almost like a TV series obviously I
loved hear your thoughts on this news
and if you're excited for the supercut
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown over whether penny wise is
alive or dead and which other Kings work
it's appeared in I'll link that at the
end so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more about the
character and its future if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just want to let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
it supercar in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on October the 15th and the blue
arrow be shipped out from then to ever
get surprised so best of luck to
everyone who takes part the channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]